uh without further ado let's just we'll
just we'll just jump right into it and
um
i'll just i'll just ask you man let's
just start talking about your your
campaign you're running for you're
running as a republican but you're
running as an america first candidate
what is that what does that mean so
america first i'm running against a
sitting republican jaime hura butler she
voted for the impeachment of president
trump that was kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back but prior to that
she had been a pretty horrible
representative and pretty horrible
republican as well so she voted to
withdraw the funding to construct the
border wall the additional emergency
funding that president trump was using
to secure our southern border she voted
in support of obamacare she voted for
the war she voted to keep our troops in
syria she went along with the whole
russian bounties afghanistan lie from
last year
so in every sense of the form um she is
exactly what we need to get rid of in
washington a career politician a
democrat a democrat exactly yeah a
democrat so it's the weirdest thing to
me i mean yeah why would someone run as
a republican but clearly be a democrat i
think she just had blind hatred of trump
she's been
very outspoken about that
in 2016 she said that she penciled in
paul ryan because she couldn't vote for
president trump and then she kind of got
quiet when trump started to actually
make progress but then every key time
that she could have stood stood strong
and actually worked in the congress to
push through some of president trump's
key agenda items that he was elected by
the american people for and that she
rode his coattails into office on
she folded every single time she felt
the old dc mainstream media lincoln
project narrative because it's easier to
do i think in dc when you're
disconnected from your people it's much
easier just to
fall in with what the mainstream media
pushes you so you're a is it fair to say
you're an anti-war kind of guy i am yeah
absolutely i mean i am not a
isolationist i think we need to have a
robust strong military we need to have
robust uh intelligence capabilities
throughout the world to keep us aware of
what's going on so we can eliminate
threats before they become a major
crisis but these endless wars the way
that we have uh really gone and done
regime change wars and then not course
corrected the times where we've really
messed up which has been the entire
global war on terror
i'm very much against those what was it
like like how did you kind of i don't
know rectifies how did you come to grips
in terms of personally like serving over
there and thinking about that that yeah
maybe you were there or that the us was
there for
nefarious purposes i don't know how you
think about it yeah um i i think at uh
well
when i first joined the military i just
wanted to go fight for my country you
know very young patriotic seeing the
1993 blackhawk down moment when i was
13. that uh that was pretty key in my
life because you know it was the first
time i think we saw like brutal combat
actually on tv like the gulf war there
was some television going on then but
actually seeing in 93 cnn uh filming
american soldiers getting drunk to the
streets i was just like wow there's guys
over fighting real evil and we're back
here in the states just kind of hanging
out so i want to go do that so and then
9 11 happened i'd already been in the
military for a couple years and so we
just trained and trained and trained and
hoped that we would someday get our shot
because that's what you want to do when
you're in the military you want to go
fight for your country
so after 9 11 we thought that we had the
most righteous mission ever
but we quickly pivoted from that so
for pretty much from the time that bin
laden and crew ran into pakistan i mean
george bush even said in april of 2002
that we changed our mission to nation
building and we were going to build
these democracies in afghanistan and the
next thing you know they're like guys we
gotta invade iraq and then they made up
all that intelligence so by the time i
got into war um in iraq i was eager to
be there but i i thought that
someone above my level knew more than me
so the first time i went to war i was i
was 23 years old i was a sergeant green
beret we were tasked with either going
out and
finding or arresting members of al qaeda
or saddam's regime and then we got
tasked with a classic green beret
mission which is to build militaries out
of local forces so we took a bunch of
the anti-saddam
militias and we started to turn them
into the iraqi security forces when i
was going through some of the rosters of
these militiamen a lot of them had huge
ties to iran their iranian fund funded
militias and then i was like
this doesn't seem like a good idea
because iran pretty much hates our guts
too you know knowing just the history of
iran and our dealings with them
so but you know in the back of my head i
was like surely somebody knows more than
me there's like generals somewhere that
have a plan did you know the history of
afghanistan and the mujahideen yes and
all that so i mean at a certain point
you're like wait a minute wait a second
yeah i mean what are you doing you put
some faith and you think that there's
somebody behind the curtain at oz um and
then
just watching how we just continued to
double and triple down on failure like
when i was in iraq when they they gave
the order to disband the iraqi uh
government and the iraqi military and
say that all these guys that were
associated with the bath party couldn't
have jobs and all of us that were on
there on the ground level we were like
this is a terrible idea this would be
like going to my
the town that my military base is in and
saying hey guys you don't have jobs
anymore we're not paying you next month
and the government pretty much hates you
and we're coming after you but leaving
us the keys to the armory i mean how do
how do you think that's going to go
that's basically what we did in iraq so
i just saw the narrative slowly get
chipped away based on what i was seeing
in the ground
um and then what was it was it
contracts the the big companies were
getting we're getting money like why
stay in there
why why did it become okay we're not
after is you know bin laden anymore it's
nation-building i think a ton of it was
hubris i mean just really at the highest
levels i mean people in the bush
administration they really believe that
neoconservative ideology that if we went
over especially in a place like iraq
because it's centrally located it does
have the potential to be independent and
to be successful and really thrive
because it looks good on paper they
thought hey if we just apply enough good
old american force and a good old
american can do like these guys are just
going to be like well thanks america
let's have an election and yeah
democracy just kicks in it just kicks in
we'll be your best friends we'll cut you
a great oil deal next thing you know you
know no but none of that actually works
so i think
people they just doubled and tripled
down on that idea because they were
embarrassed and the the bipartisan
effort that the iraq war was going back
to our current president joe biden who
was the head of the senate foreign
relations committee at the time there
was
bipartisan lying that went on to the
american people so then there became
this bipartisan game of like hey we're
all kind of part of this and then the
folks at the top levels of the military
anybody who disagreed with the way the
invasion went they got fired and so all
the yes men got promoted and they just
said hey we can we can make this work
and a lot of them i think probably had
the best of intentions they were like
hey if the u.s government's going to put
this all on our shoulders as the
military we will do the best that we we
can but at the end of the day if you
tell the military to go do stuff they're
just going to apply military tactics how
long were you in iraq
so i have about five years total on the
ground i was there pretty much every
year of the war
minus 2010 and then i went back again uh
for a withdrawal on 11 and i went back
again in the counter isis fight in 16.
that's that's that's the next question i
was going to have for you is you know
you went back to fight isis your wife
did as well
uh so this is this is a really different
kind of mission i guess so after you saw
everything with the nation building what
was it like when you know isis was was
picking up these people uh like the
caliphate was was was
truly horrifying what these people were
doing
did you have a different vision of it
like all of a sudden now you're like
this one matters
well
yeah i mean a lot of it too was i told
you so not just me but a lot of us that
were that had boots on the ground and in
when i was there in 2011 by by that time
we had pretty much handed the entire
government over to the iranians the
iranians did a really good job with
infiltrating the government of iraq
so much to the point that uh
iranian generals like qasim solmani felt
very safe running around iraq because
they knew that we didn't have the actual
political will to take them off the
battlefield iran saw that they could
kill american soldiers under bush under
obama and that we wouldn't do anything
and so they felt emboldened when we left
the country they completely and totally
took it over but when they as they were
doing that they were disenfranchising
which is to put it mildly the entire
sunni population so especially when the
syrian civil war broke out and assad was
fighting the sunnis you could just break
it down geographically as long as there
was sunnis in between the area just to
the west of baghdad and just to the east
of damascus
getting pushed by these two iranian shia
forces you had an absolute civil war so
the only means of recourse for these
sunnis was isis or al-qaeda or some form
of sunni extremists so really it
the evolution of isis is was pretty much
born the day that we invaded iraq and
then disbanded the iraqi military and
then it's it's really fascinating how
you know under obama i mean it grows yep
couldn't really do anything to stop it
but trump just
wiped it out right yeah i was there i
was there in 16 under obama and the
rules it was
most deployments in the obama era were
we have to be deployed because obama
doesn't want to pull us out because
he'll look weak but we also really don't
want to fight
you know the latter part of bush was
that way too bush was just done probably
like around i don't know 06 or 07 he was
just like i'm riding this out and you
guys are over there and i'll leave it to
the next guy to include negotiating
deals for the status of forces but obama
those those last years it was the same
thing he just he had called isis the jv
team early on and then after that he
just did not want to deal with it do you
think that uh
obama wanted isis because it was causing
problems for assad and we wanted we
wanted assad out so let isis have adam
and then we'll come and clean up we'll
sweep it up and take it once it's done
there was definitely people in his
security team in his national security
establishment that i think did want that
they very much wanted another war in
syria and i think a lot of them are
still in the government right now so i
think that permanent ruling class of
neoconservatives and neo-liberals who
you know they say different things to
justify their wars but the end the end
state is always more invasions more
occupations i i think those guys are
pulling the pulling the strings from
behind the scenes so i've had a lot of
conversations with people about trump
the abraham and abraham accords and the
conflict and uh you know on the service
i think the abraham accords did a lot of
good normalized trade between a lot of
countries and israel but we've had we've
had people say it was nothing you know
it was just like these countries were
already working together i disagree with
that i really do think that when it
comes to the israel-palestine issue
people are very tribal and just hate one
side or the other and i'm like look i
think trump was america first all the
way he didn't want to be involved in any
of this he didn't care about what it was
he said what do we do to get to end it
i'm done let's get out why are we here
absolutely so we actually had um i think
scott horton told us this right where he
said within the first three months trump
ordered a full withdrawal from from
afghanistan he like he gets in offices
get ready get him out we're done yeah
and they stopped him they said no yep
they blocked him and then we get four
years of trump and then it never
happened yeah
i mean it's just that there is that
class there in the pentagon the national
security establishment that they are i
think a lot of them
and i understand this and this has kind
of been my my
uh story of my trajectory throughout my
career
i felt that we needed to continue to
stay over there i felt compelled that
hey we need to keep going over and
fighting because we've lost so much
especially if you're in a leadership
position you're like we lost these guys
in this last deployment we've got to go
back over and we got to make it right
and i don't i don't just mean like
revenge but we got to go get something
we've given so much we got to get
something out of this i want to make it
work
and i think there is a lot of that but i
do think there's also a lot of but then
that quickly can shift into pride into
hubris really fast when a civilian
civilian leadership comes in and says
hey military guys like this isn't
working what are you doing it's like
screw you i've been fighting and dying
like what do you mean it isn't working
so i think that's but there is also a
lot of money tied up into that and a lot
of careers and there's been this whole
machinery made to keep us at war what's
that thing called where um you know
people will invest in something excuse
me sunk costs sunk costs yeah yeah
fallacy yeah and the gambler's fallacy
they keep putting more and saying no no
now is that
i already put in a million i'm not going
to lose it i'll just put another we'll
get out we'll get out we'll take
ourselves out of this hole and it's like
at a certain point man you got to be
honest with yourself at some point i
mean i really wish that i could come
here and say hey i served for for 20
years and in the five years i have on
the ground in iraq like i built this
thing and it worked and we we made the
world a better place i wish i could say
that but at the end of the day our job
is to win and our job is to do the best
that we can for our country and if we're
not being honest and saying at like the
halfway point of trying plan a that like
hey man plan a sucks it was my idea my
bad let's learn from that and let's
shift to something else but we
the government is terrible at that
political agendas but then also i mean
the military
the occupation mindset and the
occupation machinery it is very
lucrative thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you